what have you learned
about uh developing Optimus about
applying integrating this kind of real
world AI into the space of robotic
manipulation just humanoid
robotics what are some interesting tiny
or big things you've understood I was
surprised at the fact that we had to
develop every part of the robot
ourselves um that there were no of shelf
Motors
Electronics sensors like we had to
develop
everything um we we couldn't we couldn't
actually find a source of electric
motors for any amount of
money um so it's not even just efficient
inexpensive it's like anything there's
not a
no the actuators everything everything
has to be yeah designed from scratch we
tried hard to find anything that was
because you think of how many electric
motors are made in the world there's
like tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of electric motor
designs
um none of them were suitable for a
humanoid robot literally
none so we had to develop our own design
design it specifically
for for what a humanoid robot needs how
hard was it to design something that's
can be Mass manufacturer could be
relatively inexpensive I mean if you
compare to Boston Dynamics Atlas it's a
very expensive robot it is designed to
be manufactured in the same way that we
would make a car and I think ultimately
we can make Optimus for less than the
cost of a
car it should be CU if you look at
the mass of the robot is much
smaller and the car has many actuators
in
it the car has more actuators than the
robot but there is uh the actuators are
kind of interesting on a human robot
with fingers so Optimus has really nice
hands and
fingers you know yeah and they could do
some interesting manipulation soft soft
touch robotics I mean one of the tests
goals I have is can can it pick up a
needle and a thread and thread the
needle just by looking how far away are
we from that just by looking just by
looking uh maybe a year H but hello got
to go back to I'm optimistic on time the
work that we're doing in the car will
translate to the robot the perception or
the also the control the no the controls
are different but the the video in
controls out um the the car is robot on
four-wheels the the the Optimus is a
robot with hands and legs so you they're
they're very they're very similar so the
entire Machinery of the learning process
end to end is just you just have a
different set of controls often us we'll
figure out how to do things by watching
videos